bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat les sénateurs reprennent l'examen
du projet de loi notre nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république qui répartit les compétences
entre les différentes collectivités
au programme cet après midi la métropole
du grand paris le gouvernement a déposé
un amendement pour redessiner les
contours de la métropole parisienne
objectif est bien intégrée dans ce
périmètre des communes qui ont beaucoup
d'entreprises et dans le même temps et
bien faire du grand paris le trésorier
celui qui tient en quelques sortes les
cordons de la bourse
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est que le
grand paris collecte les deux taxes qui
ont succédé à la taxe professionnelle la
cfe et la cvae et qu'elle les
répartissent ensuite entre les
différentes communes le débat s'annonce
donc tendu inutile de vous dire que les
communes ne sont pas du tout contente de
cette mesure elle qui voulait plus
d'autonomie dans leurs ressources
financières tout de suite direction
l'hémicycle pour la séance
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi portant
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
république dans la discussion des
articles
nous sommes parvenus au sous-amendement
numéro 1129 rectifier à l'amendement
1104 tendon a inséré un article
additionnel après l'article 17 bis
je vous rappelle que cet amendement a
déjà été présenté est qu un
sous-amendement a déjà été
bon donc maintenant c'est un monsieur
karoutchi de prendre la parole madame la
présidente madame la ministre
ce sous-amendement rien du fait qu'il
soit co signé par philippe dallier mois
devrait faire l'unanimité de l'hémicycle
parce que tout de même tout de même
c'est pas tous les jours dimanche alors
mal à la ministre en réalité pas se
raconter la bonne aventure
on avait laissé jusqu'au 30 septembre
2014 pour adhérer à la métropole mais un
certain nombre de communes tardivement
mais les élections municipales étaient
de mars 2014
un certain nombre de communes avait
engagé le processus d'adhésion et trois
communes en l'occurrence ont délibéré
entre le 30 septembre 2014 et le 30
novembre 2014
au moment d'ailleurs de ses
délibérations nous avions demandé au
gouvernement
quel serait le sort de ces communes et
nous avions reçu un engagement écrit du
gouvernement que naturellement ces trois
communes on accepterait de les intégrer
dans la métropole du grand paris nous
voilà donc maintenant avec ces trois
communes qui ont délibéré pour dire nous
souhaitons intégrer la métropole du
grand paris le texte qui n'a pas bougé
et qui reste au 30 septembre et ce sous
amendement en réalité pour objectif de
dire madame la ministre ne veut pas
réouvrir le débat
ce que je peux comprendre pour dire même
après la publication de la loi les
décrets tu sais on ré ouvre pas le champ
de l'entrée pour ne pas déstabiliser
l'organisation territoriale au moins
pour ces trois communes ne revenons pas
en arrière par rapport à un engagement
du gouvernement
elles ont délibéré elle souhaite faire
partie de la métropole du grand paris et
nous trouvons que pour ces trois
communes nous pouvons naturellement
passer du 30 septembre au 30 novembre ce
qui permettent
de clore le débat et d'avoir ces trois
communes à l'intérieur de la métropole
du grand paris alors monsieur
capo-canellas ce pour un amendement
identique
merci madame la présidente maïs mes
chers collègues cet amendement est
effectivement identique chez peu de
chose à ajouter à ce qu'a dit
excellemment roger karoutchi issue ce
n'est que je co signe pour ma part cet
amendement avec mon collègue hervé
marseille comme quoi les hauts-de-seine
de la seine-saint-denis
chez vous comme chez nous peuvent
travailler ensemble n'est ce pas et
surtout souligner que je crois avoir
compris que un engagement écrit avait
été pris vis-à-vis de ces communes et
qu'il me semble bon qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient tenues donc si j'avais un peu de
malice je dirais que nous souhaitons
aider le gouvernement à tenir
l'engagement qui a semble-t-il était
pris vis-à-vis de ces communes jouent
simplement ajouté que la stabilisation
disons dispositif futur et des
compétences ayant pris un peu de temps
ce que chacun comprend ces communes ont
plus de bonne foi a souhaité y voir
clair avant d'enclencher définitivement
leur démarche et que de toute façon
cette option existe et pion d'adhésion
et qu'il est bon me semble qu'elle
puisse prospérer
merci est ce que monsieur favier rajoute
quelque chose sera un amendement
toujours identique
non madame la présidente on nous avons
dépendent déposé un amendement identique
effectivement pour permettre à ces trois
communes qui avaient délibéré au moment
où effectivement il y avait une
évolution profonde assure ce texte
concernant le grand paris de pouvoir
faire en sorte que lors de libération
soit effectivement validé puisque elles
ont été prises avant le 30 novembre bien
nous prenons maintenant l'amendement
11130 rectifié monsieur karoutchi il y
aura deux autres amendements identiques
qui suivront oui madame la présidente
madame la ministre en réalité si vous
nous disiez
j'espère que ça va pas que la réponse du
gouvernement on peut pas modifier le
texte et restera au 30 septembre
en réalité la seule option que l'on
aurait c'est de réouvrir le débat sur
l'adhésion à brimer ses de réouvrir le
débat sur l'adhésion et par conséquent
c'est presque un amendement non pas de
repli mais un amendement de réouverture
de la possibilité dans un délai
raisonnable après naturellement la
publication de la loi dans un délai de
deux mois
eh bien on permettrait aux communes qui
le souhaitent de recommencer ou de
refaire la procédure d'adhésion mais je
le dis franchement moi je pense que si
le gouvernement accepté l'amendement
prend fin le sous-amendement précédent
évidemment le débat serait d'une autre
nature mais en tout cas si la réponse
gouvernementale c'est de nous dire non
on ne peut pas revenir en arrière et est
considéré que ce qui a été délibérée
entre le 30 septembre et le 30 novembre
est valide
eh bien on demanderait la réouverture
pour faire de la suite après la
publication des décrets monsieur
capo-canellas ce amendements identiques
ainsi madame la présidente une précision
là encore c'est un moment à une portée
plus large parce que le premier visé les
trois communes précitées
celui ci permettrait effectivement à
toute commune souhaitant dans le délai
de deux mois après la promulgation
adhérer de pouvoir le faire
et j'insiste sur le caractère plus large
de la proposition qui me paraît pas
inutile si monsieur favier oui madame la
présidente
notre abandon chez team en commun permet
d'ouvrir à nouveau donc ce délai
permettant aux communes
qu'il le peut outre le souhait de
rejoindre la métropole du grand paris
sur la base donc de nouvelles
orientations données ou à la métropole
et donc substantiellement également on
le sait modifié et ne sachant pas
effectivement quand la loi sera
définitivement promulguée nous proposons
donc avec nos autres collègues que cette
possibilité fait aux communes
limitrophes dans la métropole soit
ouverte donc dans les deux mois après la
promulgation de cette loi
monsieur favier vous pouvez peut-être
présenter les deux suivants 11 190 11
189 rectifier oui alors tout cela va
effectivement dans le même sens et il
s'agit donc de permettre aux communes
qui ont délibéré avec retard en faveur
de leur attachement à la mgp de voir
leur demande prise en compte mais donc
ça ça rejoint la bande manqué vérité 11
189 rectifier
alors ce sous-amendement lui portent
aussi sur cette question de la date
limite qui permettait aux communes
limitrophes et sous certaines conditions
de rejoindre la métropole du grand paris
en effet l'article l 52 10 9-1 du code
en application de la map tam fixe la
date du 30 septembre 2014 comme limite
du choix possibles des communes et le 31
décembre la même année pour la décision
de l'europe et si les autorisant à le
faire par d'autres sous-amendement nous
proposons de rouvrir donc la procédure
est fixé ses échéances en 2015 ainsi les
communes devraient décider avant le 30
septembre 2015 et l'europe et ci devrait
se prononcer avant le 31 décembre 2015
ces changements de date permettrait donc
de donner le temps nécessaire donc à ces
collectivités à ces institutions puisque
la paire connaître une collectivité de
prendre leurs délibérations
en effet ne sachant pas précisément
quand donc la loi sera promulguée et
ayant évidemment cru comprendre que
l'objectif du gouvernement est de la de
le faire avant l'été notre proposition
permet que ce édition du ces décisions
du bloc communal ne soient pas prises
pendant la période des congés dont
chacun sait évidemment qu'elle est peu
propice au débat qu'une telle décision
suppose et donc à la différence des
autres sous amendement portant sur cette
date celle ci nous paraît donc
effectivement pouvoir rassembler par sa
simplicité
tel est le sens du commandement même si
tout ça effectivement donne d'edel un
peu plus longue mais on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui la mise en place de la
métropole du grand paris a pris quand
même déjà un certain retard et qu'il est
quand même assez légitime de laisser le
temps aux communes de pouvoir
aujourd'hui réfléchir à partir de ce qui
sera effectivement la loi telle que nous
allons la rectifier à travers le débat
que nous menons actuellement
merci monsieur favier monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis sur tous ses
amendements
je comprends le dépôt de ces amendements
parce que la question avait été posée
dans le la dans le texte d'ailleurs sur
la délimitation des régions oui mais pas
elle vous explique pourquoi à mon avis
et c'est un vrai problème législatif
peut-on proroger un délai qui a expiré
là c'est ça la question est donc à
partir de ce moment là et d'ailleurs
monsieur café dans son amendement
général disais bien aussi deux mois au
ruf pour deux mois mais on retrouve pour
deux mois ont fait un nouveau délai si
vous dites on proroge le délai on va se
trouver coincé novaes chers collègues
la commission des lois ne veut pas
donner un avis favorable parce que c'est
toute une histoire 16 été votée par
l'assemblée
non la supprimer mais parce que à délai
lorsque nous avons examiné le texte
le délai est expiré moi je partage tout
à fait le sentiment des collègues qui
dit écoutez moi je connais une commune
elle a loupé le truc de huit jours à ce
qui venait de s'installer le temps
qu'ils y avait un changement de
municipalité
bon c'est quand même un petit peu pis un
fils est logique
en plus de l'inclusion de la grande dans
la métropole est logique pour cette
ville il y en a deux ou trois je crois
et surtout que quand on me dit ah ouais
mais fournir bouleversé attendait dans
le texte du gouvernement
on va permettre aux communes dites dans
des secteurs aéroportuaire d'adhérer
alors elle pourrait mais une commune qui
serait pas en secteur aéroportuaire de
hausse et terminer on leur dit c'est
terminé bon ben je pense qu'il ya quand
même une incohérence quelque part donc
même madame la présidente
mes chers collègues pour ces raisons le
la commission des lois est favorable aux
amendements identiques 1130 1179
et 1188 rectifier et des défavorables à
tous les autres amendements
à mon avis ça règle le problème mais ça
ne fait de notre point de vue sur le
plan législatif que ça maintenant si
vous rouvrez le délai moi je crains bien
que y aura des recours et cetera
il y aura un problème de
constitutionnalité qu'on peut mais
monsieur bah écoutez si vous êtes plus
fort que nous monsieur vous pourrez vous
exprimer
bon mais moi je trouve qu'il ya quand
même un problème c'est tout et nous on
préfère ouvrir le délai pour deux mois
un nouveau délai pour deux mois plus tôt
que apporte à partir de la promulgation
de la loi peut pas faire autrement
ah ben on peut pas faire autrement ouais
et c'est ce que propose d'ailleurs
monsieur café aussi le g1 bassi battant
djc écrit avec la plus grande attention
bon voilà après je ne souhaite pas qu'on
fasse trop de politique politicienne
pour ces questions auteur madame la
ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente monsieur un porteur
gouvernement favorable et défavorable
aux deux solutions d'abord monsieur le
rapporteur
il ya eu effectivement de la part du
premier ministre
un accord les 8 octobre 2014 entre les
représentants de paris métropole qui
avait un texte à plus de 80% je ne suis
plus de votes favorables 94%
donc il ya eu un accord ce jour-là et un
accord portant uniquement
c'était la seule demande exprimée sur
les cas où il y avait des plates formes
aéroportuaires
c'est le seul qu'un pour lequel le
premier ministre a dit je peux
comprendre qu'il y ait cette demande et
en particulier nous avions regardé
ensemble non pas la plateforme nord
aéroportuaires mais la plateforme
sud et les accords enfin cette
possibilité devant être ouvertes avec
des accords qui ont été encadrés en
aucun cas les collectivités de la
plateforme du nord de paris n'ont
souhaité cette solution et nous n'avons
donc pas de demande avec une majorité
suffisante sur une des deux plateformes
portuaires nous avons effectivement une
seule demande sur une des deux
plateformes portuaires deux ou trois
communes par loin de la plateforme sud
sud risquent donc c'est bien à la
demande expresse et sur ce seul point
que les choses ont été j'ai envie de
dire négociée et acceptée par le premier
ministre en revanche monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez raison soit on fait
ça on trouve des délais et on est en
grande difficulté soit en fait une
validation rétroactive et à mon avis on
est aussi en très grande difficulté et
le juriste ce que vous êtes doit être
aussi mal à l'aise que moi dans un cas
comme dans l'autre
mais il ya d'autres éléments qui nous
interpelle les communes dont cav s est
limitrophe de la métropole du grand
paris se prononce donc dans les deux
mois vous l'avez rappelé qu'ils suivent
la promulgation c'est à dire le 1er
octobre 2015 et communes membres de le
pc à laquelle appartient la commune
limitrophe en question qui demande son
rattachement ont deux mois pour
s'opposer à la majorité des deux tiers
au départ de ladite commune nous sommes
le 1er décembre 2015
les projets de périmètre des
établissements publics du fameux yeux
pétillent sont transmis par le
gouvernement aux conseils municipaux des
communes membres de mgp dès que le
périmètre définitif de la ngp est arrêté
les conseils municipaux dispose ensuite
d'un délai de deux mois pour rendre leur
avis sur les projets les périmètres
nous sommes le 1er février 2007 et enfin
à une saisine bien sûr du conseil d'état
pour les périmètres en question nous
sommes le 1er mars 2016 ouvrir les
délais c'est
ne pas créer la métropole au 1er janvier
parce que c'est impossible compte tenu
de serait trop près nine que nous avons
refait à partir de ces dames en qualité
donc c'est impossible si on fait quoi
que ce soit
les deux solutions est un juridiquement
d'ailleurs attaquable et nous le savons
tous ici
dans les deux cas on ne réussit pas à
répondre à notre engagement qui
d'ailleurs a été réitérée hier soir
j'ajoute que en amont de ce fameux
octobre nous sauver mais accords
d'octobre qui n'a pas valeur de loi
bien évidemment négociations entre un
exécutif et des représentants d'élus
locaux
j'avais rappelé que avant même que tout
ça ne se mette en route après la loi
matam fait d'ailleurs le tour de
beaucoup de dates air communalité à
l'intérieur du futur maître périmètre
comme à l'extérieur je t'ai même allé
également dans beaucoup de communes nous
nous étions mis d'accord avec beaucoup
d'élus sur le fait que la métropole du
grand paris qui n'est pas régional je
sais que d'autres avaient défendu cette
position avait besoin à l'extérieur
d'elle-même de paul fort qui
s'organisent pour discuter avec air et
avoir meilleur aménagement possible et
un meilleur équilibre possible et la
grande crainte de tous ceux qui sont à
l'extérieur du périmètre
c'est de voir un certain nombre de
sources j'ai envie de dire de richesse
une manière globale que ce soit en
termes de ressources fiscales ou bien
d'emploi rentrer à l'intérieur de la
métropole et mettre en difficulté des
territoires tout autour on a bien eu ce
débat dans beaucoup de départements est
concernée au d'un au revoir plusieurs
communautés de communes ou communautés
d'agglomération on a donc pris
l'engagement de faire cette discussion
me fait beaucoup de déplacements les uns
les autres nous avons pu nous croiser
sur un certain nombre de déplacements en
question pour bienne
expliquer les enjeux à ce moment là il
était alors pas question de rouvrir une
discussion que nous avons ouvert depuis
hier donc je continue à défendre cette
position et je pense que la grande
sagesse de la haute assemblée c'est de
ne pas prendre une décision qui est
juridiquement la deuxième est bonne la
première est juridiquement inacceptable
donc repoussé et la deuxième qui nous
met en grande difficulté par rapport à
la date de la création des métropoles
dans les deux cas dans les deux cas
l'une peut être attaqué l'autre peut
nous mettre en très grande difficulté
pour que les métropoles donc c'est
pourquoi
franchement après avoir tout bien
regarder après avoir accepté la
négociation qui a été mise sur la table
par le syndicat appelait paris métropole
qui ne comprenaient pas d'autres
dispositions que celles qui ont été
acceptées le gouvernement ne peut pas
être favorable sinon nous serons des uns
et les autres en grande difficulté merci
madame la ministre alors pour
explication voc madame briques
oui madame la présidente merci notre
rapporteur nous invite à ne pas faire de
politique politicienne et j'ai pu
observer depuis le début de la
discussion sur la loi de l'autre que
chaque fois il a défendu l'intérêt
général et le droit puisque nous faisons
la loi donc moi je pense que vous
commencé très fort avec cet amendement
de rester hier je crois que c'était hier
où avant-hier je ne sais plus chers
collègues d'allier vous avez déjà secret
du coeur en disant follano mais il faut
que shell qui est en seine et marne soit
dans la métropole vous l'avez dit vous
l'avait dit lors d'une discussion je ne
sais plus trop laquelle hier ou
avant-hier donc
bon moi je voudrais vous dire ou plus à
l'appui de ce que vous a dit madame la
ministre sur les délais vous avez
commencé le suc à roxy en dix ans ne
rouvrons pas le débat il ya des communes
qui ont délibéré après mais on voit bien
quand même qu'il ya eu un changement de
la couleur politique de la ville et que
évidemment on est en plein dans la
politique politicienne
je voudrais dire à mes collègues ump de
seine et marne je vois madame mélo que
ce n'est pas en dévitalise ans la
première commune du département qui est
vrai qui c'est vrai jouxte la seine
saint denis mais qui a été placée par le
préfet de région dans une
intercommunalité est en ce moment même
il ya une cr séisme atteint mon collègue
vincent eblé président du conseil
général par ailleurs qui défend
l'intérêt de la seine et marne et bien a
proposé à la commission une grande
agglomération qui regrouperait trois
communautés d'agglomération et trois
communautés de communes avec une taille
et qui est dans l'intérêt de la seine et
marne et moi je comprends très bien la
métropole
je le comprends très bien d'une part je
pense que votre amendement va nous faire
que retarder de la rendre plus
opérationnels mais l'amdam les dix
roulent l'a dit mais surtout moi je veux
défendre l'intérêt général et l'intérêt
de la grande couronne
et quand
tout ça a commencé à être discuté mon
collègue vincent eblé a bien précisé
et il n'était pas le seul mon collègue
alain richard aussi qu' il n'était pas
question de démanteler la grande
couronne alors tout à l'heure nous
allons revenir sur les communes
aéroportuaire et vous avez un
sous-amendement qui fait sauter un
verrou camille madame la ministre dans
son amendement
et j'aurai le même sujet à proposer donc
je veux bien ne pas faire de politique
politicienne
mais je le dis du reste souvent à mes
collègues qui sont des régions autres
que l'île de france qui considère
toujours que nous sommes très riche et
qu' il faut qu'on se dévouent savez ici
c'est très difficile de faire entendre
la voix de l'île de france dans cet
hémicycle et il pense que c'est en
déshabillant la région ile-de-france
qu'on peut habiller les territoires
ruraux
ce n'est pas en appauvrissant ceux qui
ont le dynamisme qu'on va enrichir ceux
qui en ont moins
1c les mécanismes de péréquation c'est
les mécanismes de péréquation qui
peuvent qui peuvent y satisfaire et
c'est ici que nous avons fait le fonds
de péréquation nationale c'est ici au
sénat qu'on l'a fait nous étions dans
l'eau dans l'opposition dans la majorité
sénatoriale mais dans l'opposition
nationale et on l'a fait avec un
gouvernement de droite et nous avons
toujours défendu le fond ceux de
solidarité de la région ile-de-france
entre nous soit dit on en parlera quand
il s'agira de mesures fiscales il va
falloir tout refaire bon mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est pas une date
que vous nous proposez de changer c'est
le démantèlement d'un département à ce
moment là il fallait aller au bout de la
logique et ne pas défendre les
départements comme vous l'avez fait
pendant des jours et des jours au nom de
l'ump il fallait aux dires abat ya plus
de départements en grande couronne mais
s'il en reste
il faut qu'ils vivent il faut pas leur
enlever les villes les plus dynamiques
et les villes principales du département
merci madame vrai que monsieur vincent
capo calais as merci madame la
présidente de méditer chers collègues je
veux d'abord dire à madame briques que
quand je l'entends
j'ai presque eu le sentiment qu'une
confusion le mécanisme n'est pas en
cause ici la loi précédemment voté la
loma pam l'article 12 prévoit la
possibilité pour des communes de grande
couronne d'opter pour la métropole
dans ce dispositif il existe nous ne
parlons là que des dates et donc pas du
mécanisme non il faut pas nous dire que
nous instituons la possibilité pour une
ville de grande couronne de rejoindre la
métropole cette possibilité existe des
gens dont la loi donc soyons très clairs
sur ce premier point ensuite
deuxièmement sur nan parce que ben brik
nous dit finalement on va dépasser un
département de grand couronne mais c'est
pas nous c'est la loi du kaki déjà
existantes
ensuite sur les comptes les conditions
mises en place elles changent
substantiellement avec cet amendement
chacun le mesure il suffit de voir la
longueur de l'homme l'amendement et
l'amplitude des changements qui sont
proposés et dès lors il n'est pas
illogique devrait ouvrir la possibilité
pour des communes qui hier ont pu dire
dans les conditions antérieures
nous ne souhaitions pas y rentrer ces
communes peuvent réouvrir le champ de la
réflexion
aujourd'hui donc je pense qu'il est
logique d'en tenir compte en termes de
délais nous verrons bien l'effet domino
est le problème de rétro planning qui
évoque pas l'âme la ministre mais je
pense que ces questions là peuvent se
regarder et que notamment la navette
peut nous aider à régler les choses mais
si cet effet domino est si compliqué que
ça
pourquoi ne l'avez vous pas pris en
compte lorsque vous avez pris
semble-t-il engagements écrits vis-à-vis
de certains maires de modifier les dates
à aujourd'hui où nous y opposer hier
qu'il n'était pas présent semble-t-il à
votre esprit je rejoins totalement
l'analyse monsieur le rapporteur
et pour ce qui me concerne je retire
volontiers le 1178 au profit des
amendements conjointe que nous avons
avec monsieur karoutchi
donc ils sont les 1179 et 1130 qui sont
me semble-t-il plus efficace et monsieur
le rapporteur a bien voulu nous dire que
c'était la meilleure analyse juridique
donc j'y souscris avec grand plaisir
voilà ce que je souhaitais vous dire
merci monsieur d'allier
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je rappellerai tout
d'abord que dans mon rapport de 2008
je suis le premier à avoir proposé le
périmètre de la petite couronne en
fusionnant les quatre départements
à l'époque n'avait j'ai entendu c'est
qu'un monstre certains disaient c'est
trop petit faut que ça soit la région
etc etc
mais si j'avais proposé ce périmètre
c'est parce que d'abord
constitutionnellement c'était possible
que si me semblait beaucoup plus simple
de fusionner des entités existantes et
j'avais même pris la précaution d'écrire
dans le rapport qu'il ne fallait pas
donner le sentiment à la grande couronne
de vouloir effectivement la déshabiller
par morceau parce qu'à ce moment là la
question de l'existence et de la
vitalité des départements de la grande
couronne étaient posées donc je ne suis
pas un fan a effectivement du
détricotage ou du grignotage de la
grande couronne en limite de la
métropole et je reste sur cette position
ceci étant dit nous avons une difficulté
je les dis hier et voilà pourquoi
j'avais évoqué la ville de chelles
nous avons fixé ce fameux seuil de 300
mille habitants pour fixer les conseils
de territoire en respectant les
intercommunalités existantes
il y a des départements madame la
ministre et c'est le cas de la seine
saint denis où ça ne tourne pas et vous
avons beau pousser les frontières dans
tous les sens vous n'arrivez pas à
trouver quelque chose de pertinent
alors effectivement l'adjonction de la
ville de chelles permettrait peut-être
de régler le problème je comprends que
madame briques
j'en reviens sur un principe que j'avais
plutôt que j'avais plutôt édictées et je
comprends les difficultés que cela peut
poser mais si nous ne permettons pas
effectivement assez commune d'intégrer
alors il va falloir revenir sur ce seuil
de 300 mille habitants parce que ça ne
tourne pas voilà donc moi je n'ai jamais
moi je suis favorable à une métropole
intégré qui s'appuyait sur des communes
fortes et en première couronne elles
font tous en moins en tout en moyenne 40
mille habitants vous avez vous lu ses
conseils de territoire vous avez vous lu
ces pseudos intercommunalités on sait
plus que ça va être au bout du compte
pour essayer de ménager la faible la
chèvre et le chou mais ça nous pose bien
des difficultés
alors effectivement ou permet à
certaines communes d'intégrer ce qui
permet de régler
le problème des limites des conseils de
territoire ou alors madame la ministre
et j'ai un amendement qui va dans ce
sens eh bien on abaisse le seuil de 300
mille parce que sinon son nez on
n'arrivera pas à quelque chose de
cohérent et pertinent
marseille a la parole madame la
présidente pendant le ministre oui
effectivement je suis un peu surpris de
ce débat mon collègue capo-canellas a
rappelé les termes de l'article 12 de la
loi
madame j'entendais madame la ministre
qui disait il ya eu des négociations il
ya eu des discussions ce qui est vrai
avec paris métropole avec la le conseil
des élus mais c'est la loi qui l'a prévu
c'est la loi qui l'a prévu la
préfiguration je le rappelle dans la loi
map tam avait pour objet de préparer les
conditions juridiques et budgétaires de
la création de l'établissement public de
coopération intercommunale de préparer
les conditions dans lesquelles elle
exerce ses compétences également de
préparer la définition du périmètre
donc c'est normal qu'ils aient eu un
rapport qui a été remis dans le temps au
gouvernement et qui est une discussion
c'est la loi qui l'a demandé et cette
loi elle existe est préalablement ce qui
concerne les périmètres dans l'article
12 alors aujourd'hui on nous dit c'est
la défense de l'intérêt général moi je
suis comme vous madame bridge fait pas
de politique
on est ici uniquement mais non mais
c'est bien connu on est ici on est ici
pour se raconter la bonne aventure entre
gitans et pour 6,6 ça s'apparente à ça
ça s'apparente à ça et donc et donc on
fait semblant de se raconter des
histoires la vérité c'est qu'on se
raconte l'histoire il faut sauver le
soldat et blé parce que tout ça est lié
aux élections départementales
évidemment en seine et marne il faut
appeler un chat un chat et qu'à partir
de là on nous dit le président du
conseil général s'oppose parce que caen
chelles était administrée par un
exécutif de gauche ils défendent l
intérêt général
maintenant qu'il a changé de mado
majorité évidemment il ne défend plus
l'intérêt général c'est bien connu et
donc à partir de là il faut respecter ce
que demandent les exécutifs locaux
je veux dire la ville de verrières
la ville de vélizy la ville d'argenteuil
la ville de chelles
ce sont des municipalités qui ont
délibéré de façon autonome de façon
libre ils ont fait un choix et donc à
partir de là où on considère que ce que
demande 94% des élus de la métropole
on s'en moque et on s'assoit dessus ce
que demandent les municipalités on s'en
moque et on écoute simplement ce que
nous demande le président du conseil
général de seine-et-marne il nous envoie
un fax et même pas la peine qu'on vienne
et on vote par correspondance et donc à
partir de là on va défendre l'intérêt
général pour répondre à vos
préoccupations madame briques
donc moi je demande simplement aussi
qu'on écoute ce que demandent les
collectivités qui s'expriment librement
effectivement j'étais présent dans le
bureau du premier ministre avec le
conseil des élus avec paris métropole et
il avait accepté il avait accepté et par
écrit je me suis fait donner la led
j'attends qu'elle arrive il avait
accepté qu'on revienne sur ce sur ce
débat est donc c'est simplement
l'acceptation de ce que demande
librement des collectivités donc à
partir de là on peut refuser moi je
comprends parfaitement les arguments
juridiques que nous oppose madame la
ministre
il ya certainement des raisons
juridiques qui justifie que l'on soit
prudent mais qu'on ne vienne pas nous
opposer l'intérêt général l'intérêt
général c'est simplement ce que demande
librement les collectivités qui se sont
exprimés et donc ce que le rapporteur a
donné comme avis favorable concernant
l'amendement de monsieur karoutchi me
semble pertinent et à partir de là on
peut déjà dire délibérer valablement
beaucoup monsieur galton maquin la
parole oui donc nous sommes confrontés à
une question de délai avant tout puisque
c'est vrai lorsque la métropole a été
créé il était prévu que les communes qui
touchait la métropole pouvez demander à
l'intégrer et les communes qui étaient
dans des opci à cheval pouvait demander
à quitter leur pays pour repartir vers
leur département entre guillemets
d'origine donc tout ça avec les prévu
lorsqu'on a voté la métropole il y avait
un délai
il est pas un délai pour bloquer les
choses
il y avait un délai parce que derrière
ça a des conséquences en cascade et
j'entends bien que les élus du
territoire veulent quelque chose mais
les élus de seine et marne ne sont pas
forcément seconde position ça a été dit
a été dit donc on va pas commencer ici à
jouer j'ai une pétition d'élus de tel
département
une pétition de tel autre et puis voilà
on n'est pas là juste pour être les
claire de ce que décide des assemblées
d'élus on est là pour essayer de trouver
la meilleure solution possible
si la ville de chelles avait vraiment
voulu intégrer la métropole
elle avait quand même le temps même
après le changement majorité qui a eu
lieu en mars est la date était jusqu'à
l'automne alors pourquoi pourquoi ils
l'ont dépassé je ne sais pas si on
pouvait régler ce problème à l'amiable
sans difficulté mois jusqu'à le premier
je serai le premier à dire réglons le
problème mais on voit derrière toutes
les conséquences que ça et on peut pas
prendre une décision sans regarder les
conséquences en cascade
la première conséquence c'est qu'on ait
fait ça détricote complètement le
travail du préfet en seine-et-marne pour
bâtir des intercommunalités qui
lorsqu'elles touchent la métropole doit
faire deux cent mille habitants
on peut pas évacuer ce problème d'un
reversement en dix ans sylvie de 50000
habitants on leur enlève d'un côté pour
le maître de l'autre
et tant pis pour la seine-et-marne ils
se dérouleront pour arriver aux 200
milles en allant prendre des communes je
ne sais pas monsieur l'aise je
connaissais la seine-et-marne mieux que
moi donc ça pose déjà problème c'est
vrai le seul problème qui est posé
parce que les deux autres communes sont
les communes qui sont sur orly et qui
sont touchés par le deuxième amendement
puisque verrière a refusé entre paul et
a délibéré pour en sortir
argenteuil ni rentrer et vélizy n'a pas
voulu rentrer donc on est vraiment sur
ce problème de chaîne alors déjà sur
chelle c'est un problème on le voit sur
la seine et marne est difficile à
difficiles à traiter
mais alors dans le deuxième amendement
sur lequel vous semblez vous rabattre là
on ouvre la boîte de pandore
parce que
à la limite ce qu'on dit on perd mais
juste à une commune de rentrée on a une
difficulté importante en seine et marne
mais qui est limité mais si on commence
à dire on laisse jusqu'à deux mois après
la promulgation de la loi loi qui sera
promu les premiers quand monsieur le
rapporteur en août
donc on laisse jusqu'à octobre pour que
non pas shell mais toutes les communes
qui touche la métropole puisse changer
d'avis et c'est ce qu'a dit monsieur
capo-canellas l' or ouvre la boîte de
pandore
parce que qui vous dit que telle commune
du val d'oise telle commune de l'essonne
telle commune des yvelines ou même
d'autres communes seine et marne ne vont
pas dire ne vont ne vont pas dire avait
attendait ce que ce que vous propose ce
que ce que le propose le préfet dans mon
département ne me convient pas donc je
me retourne vers la métropole
on voit bien on voit bien qu en rouvrant
le délai l'art ouvre la boîte de pandore
non pas seulement pour shell
mais pour toutes les communes qui touche
la métropole alors si l'objectif c'est
de créer un foutoir énorme
il sera atteint voilà donc essayons de
régler ce problème de shell nous trouver
les solutions juridiques mais là
vraiment j insiste sur l'amendement qui
rouvre complètement la boîte de pandore
c'est créer des conflits et des tensions
sur tout le périmètre de la métropole
il y avait comme une date la ville de
chelles connaissait la date ils ont eu
tout le temps de délibérer je suis pas
rentrer dans les détails des raisons qui
ont fait qu'ils n'ont pas délivré à
temps d'autant que shell n'est pas un
petit village en une ville de 50 des
habitants
quand on délibère il faut mettre des
délais si on peut bouger les délais
s'ancrer en cascade des conséquences
néfastes pour tout le monde
bien sûr il faut bouger les délais mais
si on vous vend les délais ont créé des
conditions en seine et marne et dans
tous les départements de la grande
couronne qui seront ingérable je crois
quand même qu'il faut là monsieur le
rapporteur y réfléchir à deux fois avant
de ré ouvrir cette boîte de pandore
donc je suis contre ces amendements je
soutiens complètement la position de la
ministre qu'elle a très bien exprimer
mais tant qu'à faire si ceux qui veulent
voter un amendement venant voter un
limité quand même les problèmes à une
seule commune et n'ouvrait pas la boîte
de pandore sur toute la métropole
je crois que là il ya aussi un peu de
responsabilité jeu
comprend que les uns et les autres
cherchent à être les porte paroles de
leur département de l'eure merci
monsieur walton bas mais j'ai encore 12
secondes madame la présidente
donc avec moi et moi avec d'autres donc
je conclus pour dire qu' il faut refuser
ces amendements et soutenir le
gouvernement sur ce point
monsieur karoutchi madame la présidente
madame la ministre
il faut maintenant dire les choses et
arrêter on ne peut pas rester comme ça
jusqu'à demain soir à se raconter comme
dirait mon collègue la bonne aventure
avec ou sans gitans si vous ne voulez
pas avancer les choses sont quand même
assez simple on dit il ya eu l'échec des
six mois cette web
le gouvernement par la loi met en place
une mission on demande à cette mission
de délibérer d'avancer de travailler à
94%
elle fait une proposition et on dit
qu'on est prêt a sous-amendé
l'amendement du gouvernement qui ne
reprend pas les conclusions de la
mission
donc quand même de notre côté c'est pas
un pas c'est un pas énorme si on avait
eu cette délibération à 51%
vous pourriez dire on est soutenu mais
ça n'est pas vrai il ya 6 % seulement
des élus de cette métropole qui n'ont
pas voté cette délibération
alors maintenant alors maintenant non
non je crois qu'ils écoutent avec
attention
alors maintenant les choses alors
maintenant les choses sont très claires
sur le simple élément sur le simple
élément conforme à la loi conforme à ce
que vous avez voté conforme à ce que le
gouvernement a proposé parce que dans la
loi l'article 12 disais bien qu'il y
avait possibilité par la suite aux
communes de rejoindre la métropole
là on vous dit très bien nous on vous
demande deux mois après la publication
du texte
pour pouvoir rejoindre la métropole mais
c'est vous qui avait ouvert cette
possibilité dans la loi c'est pas nous
si on nous avait dit le territoire de la
métropole est fermée complètement fermé
il n'y a pas de possibilité de
discussion ou d'entrée on en restait là
le territoire était connue d'avancé
personne ne pouvait délibéré en dehors
et cet éclair mais là c'est vous qui
avez dit on va pouvoir entrer pourquoi
vous l'avez fait non mais pourquoi parce
qu'en réalité vous aviez une idée de
faire et moi je te pas contre après tout
le fait de faire une métropole dynamique
qui pourraient être rejointes
progressivement par des communes qui
voulaient est rentré dans cette
dynamique
alors vous voulez ça et puis dès qu'on
vous dit il ya des communes qui ont
délibéré pour y entrer en europe
non mais c'est conforme à la loi on vous
dit seulement bon ils ont dépassé le 30
septembre
mais vous votre texte on ouvrait la
possibilité d'y entrer par la suite donc
accepter qu'ils aient deux mois après la
publication les communes qui vont
délibérer à nouveau sur le coup
conformément à ce que dit jean jacques
hyest est bien entreront dans la
métropole et celles qui ne voudront pas
délibéré banon n'entreront pas mais je
vous le dis je ne comprends même pas le
débat parce que j'entends bien ce que
nous dit notre collègue nicole bricq sur
les intercoms qui se rendent qui sont
rendues compliquées par le fait de
partir mais attendez les intercoms sont
rendues compliquées par tout pardon de
vous dire dans le département des
hauts-de-seine
nous nous avons des opc qui fonctionne
très bien le fait d'entrer dans la
métropole nous oblige à les casser pour
l'échanger pour les modifier
pareil dans le val de marne enfin le la
création de la métropole
elle a des conséquences naturelles sur
un certain nombre d'interco à
l'intérieur du métro de la métropole et
à l'extérieur
alors si vous ne voulez ni toucher aux
interco en interne qu'en externe
si vous ne voulez pas laisser entrer les
communes
si vous avez alors il fallait soit dire
qu'il y avait pas de possibilité haut
rhin territoire fermé
ou alors il fallait dire que c'était la
métropole correspondant au territoire
régional
mais le côté s'est dit l'un ni l'autre
mais on peut rentrer sans pouvoir y
entrer parce qu a pas de délai
sincèrement ça n'a plus de sens
alors moi je suis d'accord avec le
rapporteur s'il le souhaite et si le
guen
on souhaite nous retirons les
amendements si cela pose problème
juridique sur le fait
antérieur d'avoir un délai etc mais
alors il faut ouvrir par définition à
deux mois après la publication
et puisque vous avez mis l'urgence sur
ce texte rien ne vous empêche de faire
en sorte que la promulgation de la loi
soit le plus rapide possible et que nous
gagnons du temps parce que si évidemment
entre elles l'homme est de lecture et
alors les deux lectures mais non les
deux lectures peuvent être terminés famé
et ben si elles peuvent être amis les
femmes et on est dans les temps mais
fait l'effort et oui fait l'effort
législatif
non mais vous pouvez pas nous dire on
refuse tout délai et puis nous dira puis
on va traîner
ah ben non vous avez mis l'urgence vous
avez raccourci le temps des commissions
on peut le faire si monsieur karoutchi
monsieur dit merci madame la présidente
permettez moi après l'intervention de
monsieur d'allier d'apporter quelques
précisions sur ce qui se passe en seine
saint denis oui c'est difficile
effectivement de créer des territoires
en seine saint denis mais c'est
difficile pour une raison qui est très
ancien qui date de bien avant la
métropole il c'est difficile parce qu'un
certain nombre de villes de
seine-saint-denis ne veulent pas se
marier avec d'autres villes de
seine-saint-denis sous prétexte qu'elles
sont pauvres et ça ça date pas d'hier et
je trouverai je trouverais absolument
étonnant est conforme pas du tout
conforme à l'esprit de la métropole
qu'on aille chercher shell pour
permettre à des villes qu'ils ne veulent
pas se marier avec nous de rester entre
elles donc je suis pour une métropole
dynamique
je suis pour une métropole dynamique
mais je suis aussi monsieur karoutchi
pour une métropole solidaire et si on
faisait ça on serait très mal partie sur
le plan de la solidarité merci madame la
présidente monsieur favier vous avez la
parole
oui madame la présidente
peut-être vous aurez fini votre dialogue
mais mes chers collègues permettrait
d'intervenir
ça a été dit à partir du moment où le
premier ministre a accepté ou avec
sagesse d'ailleurs en octobre dernier de
tenir compte de l'avis des élus à
l'immense majorité des élus de l'île de
france à 94% pour que soit réécrit ce
fameux article 12 de la loi madame il
est bien évident que les communes qui
avaient délibéré qu'il n'avait pas
qu'ils ne pourraient être confrontés
aujourd'hui effectivement un nouveau
texte de loi très différent très modifié
par rapport au texte initial
il est bien normal que toutes les
communes périphériques qui de par la loi
à 20,7 possibilité éventuellement
adhérer à la métropole
puisse aujourd'hui être réinterrogé ça
n'est plus le même texte
pourquoi parce que la métropole qui
avait été prévu qu'elle avait été jugée
inapplicable et aimer métropole
extrêmement centralisé intégrer
aujourd'hui on est sur un modèle
différent qui va garantir notamment des
moyens par exemple pour les territoires
ça change complètement la donne y
compris pour ses communes limitrophes de
savoir si aujourd'hui dans ces
conditions nouvelles
est ce qu'il y a un intérêt pour elle
d'entrer dans cette métropole ou pas et
donc il est bien normal ça me paraît
tout à fait démocratique que ces
communes puissent partir du moment où la
loi aura été promulgué avoir un délai de
deux mois pour pouvoir effectivement
adhérer ou non à la métropole alors on
nous dit ça ouvre la boîte de pandore
m'attendais c'est la loi qui a permis
cela y a rien de nouveau
certes ça va peut-être allonger un peu
les délais mais contenu déjà des retards
qui ont été pris entre nous autant faut
faire en sorte que cette loi s'applique
dans de bonnes conditions et de la
manière la plus démocratique qui soit
pour que toutes les communes puissent en
connaissance de cause
délibéré en fonction de ce nouveau texte
plutôt que d'essayer de faire quelque
chose de bâcler dans la précipitation
donc voilà donc moi je si pour des
raisons juridiques
il ya une fragilité par rapport au
premier album amendement qui était posée
par rapport aux trois communes moi je
suis prêt aussi à retirer mon amendement
et morale y est simplement donc l
amendement qui ouvre ce délai de deux
mois et nous retirons les autres
amendements
merci monsieur favier monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la parole
je crois qu'on peut peut-être voter sur
ce sujet parce qu'il y avait encore
beaucoup d'autres
enfin je vous lis 1 on est qu'au début
des sous-amendements d'ailleurs au fil
des heures il s'ajoute aux autres sous
amendement parce que votre amendement a
donné tellement l'aspiration à nos
collègues que ça n'arrête pas ah non
abbassi si vous faites ça madame la
ministre on va voter l'amendement
monsieur d'allier peut-être pour
l'amendement de monsieur karoutchi de
monsieur marseille définition savoir bon
et sinon j'ai cru que vous m'aviez
demandé la parole oui non madame la
présidente
moi ce que je ne comprends pas il faut
rappeler que c'est une initiative de
l'assemblée qui avait prolongé de deux
mois quand c'est venu et nous n'y sommes
pour rien si c'est venu tardivement le
texte évidemment le délai est expiré
on pouvait pas le ressusciter c'est ce
qu'a dit à la commission des lois c'est
comme ça oui mais nous pensions bien que
c'était un problème parce que c'est
jouer ça s'est joué à trois jours et
l'âme
franchement c'est la fin pour shell pour
shell ça s'est joué à trois jours avant
il aurait le droit mais trois jours près
c'est terminé a dit le préfet et ce
alors ça plaisait beaucoup à certains
égards
est ce que je comprends mal en plus
d'une manière générale ces cons on ne
discute plus de la même métropole que
celle de biens non non c'est plus pareil
à monsieur qu'elle donne d'accès la même
dieu dites surtout pas ça ne dites
surtout pas ça non si vous dites que
c'est la même
non pas du tout soit autrement c'était
pas la peine de se concerter et c'est
non mais ça c'est autre chose
mais même les structures sont pas les
mêmes que celles qui avaient été prévus
enfin bon ou bien alors je ne comprends
plus rien donc
et puis et puis on va permettre il
paraît que tout le monde est d'accord
aux communes dites aéroportuaire de
délibéré elle et sont même pas elles
sont même pas dans l'unité urbaine de
paris pour certaines là il ya aucun
problème de calendrier et vont pouvoir
le faire et elles pourront le faire
comment ça non mais des up
non mais je suis d'accord mais je sais
bien les opci entier mais mais il faut
quand même que les communes des libéraux
non non l'edb des communes vont pas
délibéré il faut pas les majorités
qualifiées massy comment et ben non pas
toute façon tout ça c'est contre le
droit veuillez m'excuser moi je ne
comprends pas comment on peut d'une part
son force aux forces on force dans un
sens et on interdit dans l'autre moi je
veux place sur le plan du juriste je
n'ai pas spécialement envie que celle
qui te département je vous le dis mais
moi je me place sur le plan du droit on
peut pas interdire comme ça aux uns et
pas aux autres
moi je vous le dit c'est incohérent mais
c'est pas la seule incohérence qu'on
connaît dans ses affaires un nom mais
c'est tout voilà bon ben c'est tout
c'est pour ça que je suis pour rouvrir
le délai est jeune et collègues
il souhaite retirer leur amendement qui
prolonge et puis on votera madame la
ministre je rappelle deux choses d'abord
lorsqu'il est le premier mort
amendements je parle de l'article 12 de
la loi map tam sur cette ouverture on
avait appelé à un amendement anti tache
d'huile
se posant à la thèse
que développer monsieur karoutchi tout à
l'heure en dix ans une fois qu'on aura
mis la métropole en place les
intercommunalités autour qui fonctionne
il faudra surtout pas que commune après
commune au gré des opportunités
le périmètre de la métropole bouge
c'était bien et vous reprenez les débats
moi je me souviens avoir été aussi
extrêmement claire dans les discussions
concernant cet article 12 d'autant je
vous le rappelle que nous étions sortis
du sénat sans article du tout à la
demande du sénat et que nous sommes en
train de nous rapprocher de la position
initiale du gouvernement à l'entrée au
sénat mais monsieur le rapporteur moi
j'entends ce que la question que vous
posez il ya eu effectivement on peut le
regretter disent certains l'applaudir
disent d'autres une négociation avec un
certain nombre d'élus même si on sait
bien qu'un exécutif ne doit pas se
soumettre à une assemblée d'élus en tout
cas il ya eu un accord de l'exécutif
pour prendre en compte les propositions
du syndicat appelait paris métropole à
94% et c'est dans cet accord en octobre
figurait la possibilité d'intégration à
la demande du syndicat paris métropole à
je dis bien due à la demande du syndicat
de paris métropole demande donc de la
mission de préfiguration dans son entier
bien sûr la possibilité d'intégration à
la mgp des communes membres de paix si
accueillant des infrastructures
aéroportuaires s'était dit extrêmement
précisément pourquoi parce que une plate
forme aéroportuaire c'est pas un outil
industriel anodin c'est une plate-forme
de transport et qui appelle une mobilité
entre la métropole et la plateforme en
question
le premier ministre a entendu
qu'effectivement on ne pouvait pas
traiter de la même façon et plateformes
aéroportuaires que d'autres
je rêve commune industrielle pôle de
développement on a beaucoup parlé du de
saclay on a beaucoup parlé d'autres
grands de réussite qui sont actuellement
et qui seront donc en dehors de la
métropole mais comme une demande dans ce
cas là je reviens à mes plates formes
aéroportuaires ce qui a été dit c'est
l'option que nous avions accepté les
communes membres de pci accueillant des
infrastructures aéroportuaires se
prononce dans le mois qui suit la
provence dans le moi je dis bien qui
suit la promulgation de la loi nome sur
leur intégration à la ngp 1er septembre
les projets de périmètre des
établissements publics de territoire les
ep t sont transmis par le gouvernement
aux conseils municipaux des communes
membres de la mgp dès que le périmètre
définitif de la ngp est arrêté les
conseils municipaux disposent d'un délai
de deux mois pour leur avis sur les
projets de périmètre même le président
nous a appelés à cela des et péter soit
le 1er novembre 2000 tonnes la saisine
du conseil d'état et l'examen par le
conseil d'état du décret fixant ce
périmètre
le siège de péter dure un mois nous
arrivons au 1er décembre 2015
donc c'est à la fois l'accord qui avait
été donné la démarche thème quel est le
rétroplanning tel qu'il est donc dans
cette hypothèse où seules sont
concernées les plateformes
aéroportuaires nous réussissons à
boucler le tout juridiquement le 1er
décembre 2015
donc la métropole démarrant son exercice
le 1er janvier 2016 femme ça fonctionne
dans l'option 2 qui est une option
différente le rétroplanning en cas de
réouverture de la faculté pour les
communes limitrophes de la mgp 2 reçoit
la mgp une seule commune membre d'un
opci existants
c'est bien dans ce cas de figure que
nous sommes c'est à dire que c'est une
commune qui veut rentrer dans la
métropole qui quitte seul à le pci
donc c'est tout à fait différent du cas
qui a été
apprécié pour les plateformes
aéroportuaires nous ne sommes plus du
tout dans le même cas de figure
et dans ce cas là ce que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure sur le rétroplanning
puisqu'il s'agit d'une commune qui va
quitter son pays pour rentrer dans la
métropole
nous ne pouvons pas en tirant les délais
au maximum et en disant même conseil
d'état qui note à moi et pas un jour de
plus nous arrivons au 1er mars 2016 et
donc nous ne pouvons pas sur cette idée
là même accepté cette possibilité et
nous avons je viens où vous écoutiez
vous aviez ne monsieur le rapporteur ou
bien reconnaît et je pense que ce serait
peut-être intéressant de le rappeler
nous avions une loi loi qui a été votée
c'est doit s'appliquer
cette loi s'applique et elle a été votée
elle est revenue ici au sénat elle a été
votée elle était votée à l'assemblée
nationale aussi et c'est le sénat
d'ailleurs qui a généré la recherche de
cette métropole en question en refusant
une première solution que le
gouvernement d'apporter nous avons
accepté contre la vie par exemple de
monsieur gaudin qui a fait un grand
exposé dans un grand colloque à
marseille en disant qu trouvait
inadmissible qu'on rouvre si peu de
temps après un texte qui venait d'être
votée nous avons accepté d'écouter les
propositions syndicats de paris
métropole et des 94 % ou même 100% peu
importe des élus concernés nous avons
pris en compte des propositions et nous
avons donc déposé au nom l'exécutif un
amendement dans cet amendement nous
respectons l'accord 2014 pour lequel
nous avions déjà le rétroplanning que je
viens de vous dire qui nous permet
d'arriver au 1er décembre 2000 tonnes
pour les plateformes aéroportuaires au
sens de l'intérêt général et en
particulier il faut puisque vous rentrez
dans certains détails athis-mons paray
vieille poste
dès le départ ont demandé à pouvoir
rentrer dans les métropoles pour des
raisons de ressources concernant
l'aéroport d'orly puisqu'une partie de
la plate forme aéroportuaire et dans la
métropole d'ores et déjà et une partie
de la plateforme elle-même compris le
bout des pistes avec des hangars et en
dehors de la métropole
c'est ce qu'alain que le premier
ministre a bien voulu regarder dans
l'autre cas le pci apparemment n'a pas
fait cette demande je ne sais d'ailleurs
comment cela se passe et je n'ai pas à
regarder de plus près pourquoi nous
n'avons que cette demande
moi je respecte au nom du premier
ministre l'entièreté d'un accord
difficile d' octobre 2014 qui nous
permet d'accepter une évolution et
d'arrêter l'ensemble en 1er décembre
2015 le l'autre dans l'autre hypothèse
effectivement on retrouve ce contre quoi
on s'était battu sur la métropole tâche
d'huile dont certaines communes avec des
outils importants peuvent intégrer les
métropoles la métropole elle même un
certain nombre d'élus dans l'intérieur
du périmètre de la métropole souhaite va
rentrer certains outils parce que la
ressource rentrerait avec les communes
en question mais ce nous nous sommes
engagés dans le même temps à ne pas
mettre à genoux ceux qui ne sont pas
dans la métropole c'est à dire à laisser
à l'extérieur des plateformes
industrielles importantes de recherche
de haute technologie et pour certaines
communes et je parle à roissy
particulier nous avons quelques communes
au nord qui nous dit c'est la seule
solution pour nous pour trouver des
solutions des problèmes d'emploi de gens
qui sont en grande difficulté c'est que
vous ne fassiez pas rentrer les deux
trois communes qui vont le mieux dans
l'air de roissy et nous nous laisser sur
le bord du chemin définitivement avec
une vallée entre les deux